All right.
That is the shift to where we start, I guess now.
All right, well, so welcome.
Good to see you tonight on this Wednesday, digging deeper,
and, uh, hope you had some good chicken enchilada Cas oil.
So good. Um, so tonight should be fun.
This'll be an interesting one of all of them.
This is probably the most debated
of all the subjects we've studied so far,
because there are wildly divergent views on this.
And we'll talk through some
of those tonight as we dig deeper.
Uh, but you know, I love Charles Spurgeon,
and so I wanted to start with a quote just to kind of color
our evening and really our thoughts on it about really
why we, we do talk about it, of course, and we should.
But, um, why we don't talk about it all the time.
And so let me give you this quote.
Spurgeon said, I think some ministers would do far more
for the prophet of God's people
if they would preach more about the first advent
and less about the second.
So the idea is that we,
we should prioritize the first coming of Christ
and what that meant for his people and for us.
But also we can't ignore it.
The second coming, the second advent,
that word advent is appearing.
So we can't ignore it.
And so that's why we've made it one of the big rocks, is
'cause it is a part of our faith
and it's an essential part of our faith.
And so we have to hold up what is essential
and what is less or non-essential in that.
Now, I said these things on Sunday,
I'm gonna say 'em again just to preface our time.
I cannot, we cannot answer every question you have.
Uh, we could spend years in this room doing that.
And so we can't answer every one of those. That's okay.
Uh, because there are some we will not know the answer to
until it actually happens,
and we won't be able to fully nuance and every detail
and everything that you would think
or I would think is the the most important issue.
We just can't dig into all of those.
Uh, and, and really that's okay again,
because there's elements of this that we need
to see are important and essential.
But we also need to understand there's stuff that is
third level, third tier issues that we can disagree on
and still be in the same small group, the same church.
And we can dis differ and disagree, and that's okay.
But there are the elements that I said on Sunday
that we can't deny and still call ourselves Christian.
So there's an essential piece,
and we're gonna talk about those things that are more,
salvific is the word we use.
The the saving first tier issues that we talk about.
Uh, those are things
that we're gonna quickly touch on again, uh,
but we're gonna get to some
of those third tier issues tonight and,
and talk about the differences there.
But I want to ask this question.
Isn't it interesting that Jesus coming back
for his bride, which in
so doing will unify us all together?
And this is the universal church.
I'll talk about this Sunday a little bit.
All believers from all times
and all around the world, God,
in his redemption
and Reese constitution of everything will
unify us all together.
Jesus, coming back for that bride to unify us is actually
what often divides us.
We become more evangelistic about these third tier,
these third level issues than we are
about the one body being taken home to be with him forever.
Like that should be our primary task, our primary focus,
our primary energy should be spent on that
rather than these other things.
This should not be a dividing point for us.
It should be a unifying point for us.
These things that are essential.
So we went through Matthew 25 on Sunday
and looked at, it's it's main big rock items, right?
And so we saw things like Jesus is the one who's going
to return simple truth.
We know that coming in his glory,
which means he's gonna come visibly, uh,
the debate will be win, but we'll talk about that later.
And he's going to come to judge.
So he's not coming back just to hang out
with, uh, people on earth.
He's coming back to judge
and separate the sheep and the goats.
And there's even debate about how many judgments there are
and when those judgments happen.
And so we'll get into some of that too.
But, but you can begin to see how, okay,
even just the basic truths we get all over the place
when we have to apply those and,
and figure out the, the nuance and details of those.
But he is coming back to judge. We know that's true.
Uh, and he's coming back to judge so
that some will go to eternal life.
Some will go to eternal punishment.
And that's eternal life is God's kingdom.
Uh, his blessing, joy, eternal face-to-face with God.
That's the best part about it.
I asked the question, what if you could have all
that heaven would give you, yet Jesus wasn't there?
Would you still take it?
Well, it's maybe just about what I'm getting out of it,
instead of being in relationship with God,
which is the most important piece.
So don't miss that. That's the eternal life that begins now.
We're made alive in Christ. We have eternal life even now.
Uh, but that will one day be fully
and finally eternally given in that life.
But then the eternal punishment's, the other side of that,
that some will be, uh, raised to, to, to life
eternal punished in that, that's where the goats ended up.
He called it eternal fire. Uh, there's no way around that.
That's a literal fire.
Literal hell with an unquenchable flame.
Um, some deny hell, of course, but,
but we can't use it as some kind of symbolism
because it stands for something worse than that then, which,
that's what is worse.
And how would you even want that to be worse than that?
It's for the devil pit cursing the fire.
It's what God's word over and over throughout scripture
says, a variety of things about that I wanted to read.
So thinking about those essentials,
those big rock items I wanted to read, um, what our,
our statement of beliefs on our website says about the last
things, just to kind of give you a summary of what, uh, we
as elders have come up with, says,
the earth will not exist in its current form forever.
Big changes are coming.
Everybody lives forever after they die.
Christians will go to heaven to live with God.
And non-Christians will go to hell to live forever
separated from God.
Jesus now sits on a throne in heaven beside God the Father.
That's the second one tonight, right?
Um, Jesus now sits on a throne in heaven
beside God the Father,
although no one knows what day it will be, Jesus will return
to earth in power and glory to judge all people
and to make all things new,
simple, right?
Just basic big rock stuff.
That's what we would stand on.
And, and those are the things
that would make this distinctly Christian.
A lot of the other things we start debating on are,
are Christian, but, but they're not the essentials, right?
We can differ on those. This is the core.
Those are the things that we must believe
or we can't really call ourselves Christian
in our belief system.
Then what we don't know, it's mentioned in there, is
what we don't know is when Jesus will return win.
And in many ways, some of the patterns of order
of operation, how we'll talk about that a little bit,
but this is what divides us so often is when
will Jesus come back?
And many people have, have predicted that Nostradamus,
I don't even know who that guy is,
but I see his name on the thing right
by the supermarket checkout stand all the time.
And he's always predicting when the world's gonna end.
Well, we don't know.
And anybody who says they know are lying
cults throughout history have used that
whatever date they came up with as a way to say, you need
to follow me or us because we have this way
and we know when it's coming.
And so we can prepare for it.
That's a dangerous place to be. Jesus himself said that.
Don't somebody's gonna say, look here,
it's coming here, it's coming.
And Jesus said, don't. No, no, don't listen to 'em.
Don't listen, because they don't know.
We can think we have some signs of things,
but, but really we don't.
And so what happens then?
I, I said this Sunday, is that when we start
to think about those hints, and he says, wars
and rumors of wars and earthquakes
and, uh, the, the gospel going to all nations,
there's all those kind of hints that we think, okay,
we can identify when and where,
and well, this is who that person is.
The problem is Jesus never intended for us to do that.
That this pope is the antichrist, we're certain about it.
Well, then he dies and we're like, well, maybe not.
Um, that nation is Babylon, right? It's gotta be.
Well, it turned out they weren't.
So we can't get so dogmatic fixed on
what we would say this
or that is this specific thing in Revelation.
And and in this part of Ezekiel, it says this,
and we need to be really cautious.
It's okay to believe
and to think through those things, absolutely.
But just be careful in making such dogmatic statements.
'cause he never intended for us to do that.
The nature of apocalyptic literature is that it's difficult
to understand and there's ways
to interpret it very differently.
So we need to be careful with that.
Uh, I gave that joke and,
and even Steve a second ago gave
that joke about, are you pan?
Are, are you pre-millennial? Are you post-millennial?
Are you all millennial? We'll see all
those things here in a second.
Well, this guy said, I'm pan millennial.
It's all gonna pan out in the end. That's true.
We can't use it as an excuse not to really work at believing
and understanding these things.
But it is the truth
that it will pan out in the end how God wanted it to.
We know he is promised to return.
So our job is to stay awake, all the parables, stay alert,
stay ready, keep the lamps lighted, all of that.
And the reason he hasn't told us is
because then we'd start just living loose
and we'd say, well, we know the date.
We already know the time. So I can do kinda whatever
I want till that week ahead.
Then I really need to clear some stuff up
before he comes back.
And it just defeats the whole purpose.
So he hasn't told us so
that we can just stay ready all the time.
So what do we do with it? Of course,
I said, there's, there's four things.
There's more, of course, there's just four things.
Uh, what we do with all this is not just debate it,
but we live in response.
First, we believe wholeheartedly.
Um, and that was that idea that it's not works-based.
It's that God has done what he's done
for us in salvation.
Our job is to believe.
And so Ephesians two, Romans 10
talks about that, that that's the crux
of the matter, is belief.
And then what happens from there is of course
that the life is transformed.
Ephesians two 10 continues
that these good works, he's prepared.
That's what our lives then look like, is
what he says in Matthew 25.
That changes happen.
So, and I, I said this, I wanna say it again.
Virtually every time
the New Testament talks about the return of Christ,
it is immediately followed by an exhortation
to godliness and holy living.
So if it happens that often, even the book
of Revelation says, keep this, not just like hold it,
keep it, obey it.
Live a life of righteousness.
If that's always coupled together,
then we should identify that.
That's one of the reasons He tells us
that this end is coming, is to prompt us
to live lives.
That would reflect we're waiting on our king to come back.
That's what our job should be. We've missed the whole point.
If that study of the end times doesn't conform us more
to Jesus in our lives, we also talked about going
that because of this.
Like, I know I got eternal life so I can risk,
uh, we can't miss evangelism.
That Spurgeon quote again of,
I deeply regret when I see persons
so taken up with prophecy.
They forget evangelism, trumpets
and bowls must not displace the gospel in its invitations.
Like this is the point.
Let's not just sit here and debate all these things,
but the gospel going forth is what he's called us to.
And it's scary. But risk is fine
whenever we know that there's hope on the other side of it.
So we can take risks, know that God's got us.
But then the last point was, wait, expectantly,
that there's a measure of of not knowing when,
but as we wait doesn't mean just kind of sit back
and passively wait.
It's wait with an expectancy.
And that's that long Campbell Morgan quote that,
uh, it's dark.
We know it is. Yes, but it was dark in Rome.
It was really bad back then in various times and ways.
And so we could lament
or we could be like the New Testament church,
which lived in this spirit of triumph,
that there's a note of victory.
Everything we see throughout the New Testament,
think again, look again, judge.
Not by the circumstances of the passing hour,
but by the infinite things of our gospel and our God.
He says it earlier, I kind of, I went quickly through it.
I, I, if ever I'm tempted to think
that religion is almost dead today, it's when I listen
to the wailing of some Christian
people, I think we get there.
We as a church, as Christians in a, a world like we live,
where you keep hearing these news stories about
how dark everything is, how bad everything is,
and we just start lamenting.
And we start talking. Woe is us. Look how bad this is.
Why is our life so hard? Why is our nation so bad?
Why is the world so fallen? All these things.
If ever I'm tempted to think
that religion is almost dead today.
It's when I listen to the wailing
of some Christian people, that's the truth.
We, we should of all people have a note of triumph
because we know the end of the story.
We know that this is not it.
We get the opportunity on the backside of this
to have life forever with God.
Great, great, great news, right?
So let that filter into today.
When we look around and yes, we don't enjoy sin
around us, darkness in our families, we don't enjoy that.
But let the hope filter the way we see today.
Wait for the Lord, be strong. Let your heart take courage.
Wait for the Lord.
I think one of the phrases you often hear
when things are really hard, we say,
come quickly, Lord Jesus.
Right? Don't we say that? You hear that?
Say, come quickly, Lord Jesus, even at the end
of Revelation 22, we get that it's true.
But man, we say that only the times when it's hard,
come quickly, Lord Jesus, get me out of my suffering.
Shouldn't this be the joy of our lives?
That, that we get not only new heavens
and new earth, no pain, no suffering, no sin.
We get that come quickly, Lord Jesus. Yes.
But we get to see our Lord face to face.
So even if, even if things are really good
in our lives right now, come quickly, Lord Jesus.
'cause I wanna see you. That's what I want.
That's what I long for above all else.
One thing I desire, dwell in the house of the Lord forever.
Psalm says, so come quickly, Lord Jesus,
not just when everything's falling apart, come quickly.
Lord Jesus, all day, every day. Vance Havner said it.
The early believers were not looking
for something to happen.
They were looking for someone to come.
Looking for the train to arrive is one thing,
but looking for someone, we love to come on
that train is another matter, right?
So let's be expectant waiting that
our king is coming on that train.
Not just to make everything better for us,
but our king is coming.
That's the goal. Alright?
So we're gonna dig into now a little bit of
the how do we interpret the book of Revelation?
That's the, so we're getting into the third level stuff now.
Now, right? The sand.
This is where we can differ on some, some things.
And, and it's okay. We can have debates and questions
and talk differently about it.
Yes. How do we interpret the book of Revelation?
Well, here's, here's one quote, one statement.
It cannot mean to us what it did not mean to them.
Here's what that means. It cannot mean to us
what it did not mean to them.
So that's kinda the idea we're getting to with, okay,
we're trying to pinpoint history.
Who's this? Who's that? They had no idea Russia
would exist 2000 years ago.
So it can't mean to us what it never meant to them,
what it would not have meant or did not mean to them.
So we have to think through the lens there to understand
that, okay, apocalyptic language does
have a lot of symbolism.
It does have a lot of things that can mean multiple things.
It, it's hard, but it can't mean what it never meant.
So just keep that in mind as you go through your study,
as you think through it, it can't mean what it never meant.
So let me just talk through a few things about
that kind of idea.
When you think about the book of Revelation or,
or any apocalyptic literature, uh, there,
why is it so uncertain?
Why are we so uncertain about these things?
If an event is prophesied, it'll surely happen, right?
Well, yes, but there's complicating factors here.
How will it happen? When will it happen?
Interpretation complicated by a couple things.
First, symbolism, there is a lot of
debate over whether something like Revelation 13,
I saw a beast rising outta the sea.
10 horns, seven heads, 10 dims on its horns,
blasphemous names on its heads.
The beast I saw was like a leopard.
Its feet were like a bears.
Its mouth was like a lion's mouth.
Okay, that sounds like a Godzilla movie in some ways, right?
So either that is literal
it, it's probably not.
I mean, maybe it is. I'm not gonna die on that hill,
but it's probably not.
So since it's a figurative idea, then it's open
to various interpretations.
What do those crowns mean?
What is the, how many heads does it have?
Well, why does that mean? Is it 10 Roman emperors?
And, you know, you could start going
through all kinds of things.
It's anybody's guess and everybody
does guess about it, right?
So that's part of the difference. Symbolism.
Then there's typology,
which is also like multiple occurrence effect.
So there's times in one Corinthians Romans where Paul says,
events that previously occurred in the Old Testament,
where really future predictions called types of things
that happen again in the New Testament.
So e Egypt people
of Israel fleeing Egypt, crossing the Red Sea.
He uses that to say,
Christians fleeing sin baptized in the blood of Christ
through the Red Sea in a sense.
So an event can happen twice, more than twice.
Like you, you see how that complicates the interpretation.
Uh, there's also some of similars called the double peak.
Double peak effect, where one event is really two events,
and there's prophets that are in the Old Testament looking
ahead and they see all
of events in the future happening once, um,
all future events happening at once, I should say
even if the two events are separated by an expansive time.
So you think like you're seeing, um,
you're looking from one side
and you're seeing what looks like one mountain
with twin peaks.
But what you don't realize is you're looking at two
mountains that are separated, right?
So there's a measure of that happening even in prophecies.
So some of the elements of what this,
like Isaiah nine is an example for, to us,
a child is born, uh, to us.
A son is given. Isaiah is looking ahead 700 years.
And some of this was fulfilled when Jesus came.
A son is given, child is born,
the government shall be upon his shoulder.
Well, that's somewhere out there, right?
Not at the same time of zero whatever year
it was when Jesus was born.
His name shall be called wonderful counselor. Okay?
That's true. Mighty God.
Everlasting Father, prince of peace, yes, of the increase
of his government peace, there'll be no end.
Okay, well that sounds that way.
So like he's looking ahead
and he's seeing all of this happen as one event,
even though it's multiple events.
Two, at least that happening at different times. See that?
So that's the double peak effect that complicates prophecy.
The conflation effect is another one.
Two events are really one.
So first century Jews looked for two different figures
who were prophesied in the Old Testament.
One was the kingly Messiah,
the other was the suffering servant.
They did not know.
And the Old Testament scriptures don't,
don't make it really obvious that both
figures were one and the same.
So they're looking for a messiah and a suffering servant.
They didn't realize that that's actually coming in God,
the Son in flesh.
So you can see how this is so complicated, right?
All of those things make, when you look at prophecy
and you look at these things like, whew,
I don't which one is it?
That's why there's so many different ways to interpret this,
which is why we have to be really loose in our handling of
what we believe and dogmatically say.
Now, here's another question people have about that.
Is Christ scheduled to return next?
Is that the next thing that's going to happen?
Well, this is a way we can disagree.
'cause there's varieties of arguments for both sides of it.
Is it the very next thing that happens according
to prophecies, or is some other things supposed
to happen before we get there?
Well, there's some scriptures that argue
that Christ is returning next.
That's the very next thing that would happen.
And there's urgency in some of these.
Matthew 24, stay awake.
You don't know what day your Lord is coming be ready.
The son of man's coming in an hour. You don't expect.
That seems to indicate that's urgent next.
But then there's others that think
that there should be other things that happen
before Christ return.
This is the preaching of the gospel to all nations.
Mark 13, the gospel must first be proclaimed to all nations.
Has that happened yet? You could say yes,
but you could also say, no, we don't know.
Uh, then there's language about the great tribulation, uh,
that is that happening now?
Is it going to happen someday?
And there's debates about those things, right?
So even those, there, there's stuff that could happen
before, uh, like antichrist, false prophet, salvation
of Israel and how that plays out.
If that's a full salvation
or if it's gonna be partial signs in the heavens.
You got all the sun
and moon going dark, you got earthquakes,
you got wars, all of those things.
Are those gonna happen before? Have they already happened?
We could say yes, but we also say no.
That's what we're talking about.
There's a lot of disagreement.
What we don't, what we do know.
Again, I said it Sunday, has Christ already returned? No.
So we know that's still out there.
Other things we're not a hundred percent sure about yet.
So there you go. You got some of those complications
and factors that come into it.
Okay? So let me talk now about these.
I I'd say schemes that sounds negative,
but scheme is merely like a, a structure of
how various people determine
or signify what's going to happen.
The order of events, the timing of the end.
So this involves talks about the rapture, which is, uh,
a belief that God is going to kind of, in many ways,
invisibly remove his believers, either partially
or fully at one time, kind of surprisingly to the world,
just kind of poof, they're gone.
Uh, it involves, that involves the
millennium thousand years.
Revelation 20 talks about that.
Is, is that a literal thousand years
or is it kind of figurative?
There's questions there.
And then in relation to the tribulation,
some people will say it's seven year tribulation,
or is it extended or is it partial?
And those kind of things. So these are just ways, again,
there's problems with all of these,
but I wanna show you these, at least just give some exposure
to what is out there, because maybe you've heard one
way, specifically your whole life.
Maybe you read a series of books
that portrayed one specific way, uh, that
that could be right, it could be wrong,
but this is just a variety of ways
that people interpret this.
So the first one I wanna show you is called
ah, millennialism.
Uh, this, uh, we'll put 'em up on the screen.
Hopefully you can see, and maybe you can't see it perfectly,
but at least you'll get a picture for it, a millennialism.
So ah, means no.
Anytime you see that at the beginning of the phrase,
a millennial, there is no future millennium at all.
Uh, what they say is, we have that, Jonathan. Yeah.
Okay. So this would be a millennialism
where you can see that the millennium is happening now
in the church age, this is the millennium and it's, uh, or,
and or happening to dead believers who are now in heaven.
There's no rapture involved here.
There's no real tribulation involved here in the sense
of seven years or anything like that.
Christ's death, resurrection, ascension
began the millennium.
Uh, the kingdom of Satan
and church is in stalemate, kind
of fighting it out in a way right now.
Uh, millennium is in heaven only.
The earthly church is always in tribulation.
There's not a seven year thing.
It's kind of all happening right now
until the final rebellion, which is at the moment
of Jesus's return.
That all happens kind of conjunctively.
So here's some strengths and weaknesses. Pro it's simple.
It's clear Christ returns.
Once there's an end, a scripture seems to indicate it,
it cleans up the end a lot.
The con is, it seems to ignore or wanna explain away.
Revelation 20, which talks about Jesus reigning
for a million or a thousand years, uh,
the Satan being locked away for a thousand years.
Uh, and then another con is
that Christ's return is not next.
Other things happen before his return.
So all the scriptures that debated that this is one way
that there is no technically thousand year millennium.
It is all happening right now.
That's one, uh, post, post millennialism is the next one.
And you'll see that coming up here where Christ will return
after the millennium post means
after, of course, uh, it tends to believe
that the great tribulations already occurred.
Uh, there is no rapture.
The millennium is figurative in the sense
that Christ's kingdom is growing in our hearts right now.
That his millennium, his is, uh, is right now happening
inside of us in a sense
that his rule is growing on the earth right now.
Uh, that the great tribulation was in Ad 70 when Rome
destroyed Jerusalem.
That was kind of all around that time.
And we've now gone into it. It's also simple and clear.
Christ returns once there's an end, as scripture seems
to indicate it, it also makes that revelation 20,000 years
metaphorical again in this day and age.
So it does apply Revelation 20, but it also talks some cons.
It also talks a lot symbolic about these scriptures.
There's no indication in the text they
should be interpreted symbolically.
A lot of them are because of this.
It was also really popular before World War I.
So, uh, everybody was like, man, things are going great.
Things are progressing,
and then the world falls apart in World War I
and people kind of like, uh, maybe that's not true.
Maybe it's not progressing all the way
towards when Jesus returns.
That's maybe a little bit there.
Um, so it's not as widely held anymore.
The world no longer seems to be progressing into harmony
and becoming universally Christian, which is kind of
what this indicates.
Uh, and Christ returns not next.
Other things have to happen. So that's another one.
Post millennialism.
Here's the next one, dispensational, pre millennialism.
Now, there's a variety of versions of this one.
So dispensational, I mean, dispensational like God kind of
dispenses his grace, presence,
salvation in some different way.
They, there's extreme versions that he saves differently,
but I don't think that's where anybody would be, um, uh, uh,
that he works in different ways, in different times,
dispenses things.
And so pre millennialism would be that God does something
before this millennial timeframe.
There's two versions.
There's pre Tribulational, which is this one,
and then we'll get to another one here in a second.
Uh, but what this is, this involves the rapture.
This one is when you read the left behind books
or watch the left behind movies, this is this to a T.
Um, there's a rapture of the church secret.
The tribulation happens for seven years.
Then there's a second coming where Christ comes
with the church to begin the millennium a thousand years.
And then the last judgment happens,
and then eternity happens.
And so there's some prose to this that the scriptures,
some would indicate
that Christians will be delivered from the hour of testing,
won't be in the tribulation, the wrath of God.
We won't feel any of that.
So pre-trib, you're out before the tribulation happens.
But other scriptures, this is a, a con to this.
Other scriptures say that Christians will suffer
and die even during the tribulation.
So there's some scriptures
that kinda go back and forth on that.
Uh, another pro is that the, the phrase,
the church is not mentioned by name in the book
of Revelation after the first three chapters.
So did God take them before all of the rest of we could be?
Um, but that's not a sufficient argument.
That's an argument from silence, which is not always, uh,
a good evidence appeal to ignorance that we just
'cause we don't know it's there or not.
We think it's not Well, that's not
evidence against it being there.
You don't see Buicks
after the book of Revelation chapter three either.
So it doesn't mean they're not there.
It's so you see it, it's like an argument from silence.
Um, Christ will be returning
as another pro at the end of the tribulation.
So true believers will have to be raptured earlier.
So the church comes with him, okay, maybe.
Um, but there's no way that,
there's no reason the church could not meet Jesus in the
clouds and immediately turn and come back to Earth.
So there's all kinds of debates there.
There's also a, the next one is mid trib, pre boy.
These are hard words to say.
Mid trib dispensational, pre millennialism
say that three times fast.
This is where the tribulation starts.
And believers are involved in the tribulation just midway
through, halfway through three and a half years.
Three and a half years. The rapture happens there.
Um, the great tribulations,
the back half of the seven years.
Um, okay, great distinction,
but the Bible never says anything about that.
So we're kind of making that up in some ways.
Um, and then God's wrath and some things like there,
but that, that's a harder one to defend.
Then this last one,
there's probably more, but I'm just giving you another one here.
This is classic or historic pre millennialism.
This is what most before, uh, Darby
and Schofield and Rry in the late 18 hundreds.
They are the, the purveyors
of this pre-millennial dispensationalism, um, pre-trib,
that kind of stuff that didn't come till late in the 18
hundreds really promoted this one.
This pre-millennial stance was long before that.
So that's why they call it historic pre millennialism
that Christ will return before the millennium, but
after the tribulation, there's only one second coming.
Um, so strengths
and weaknesses, it's clear, it reads this catal scriptures
literally when it can, uh, you don't dismiss some of it.
The other thing though, it's a negative, is
that Christ's return is not next.
Other things happen first, which
again, scriptures seem to indicate.
Maybe it does, maybe it doesn't.
You can put that back up there.
Leave it up there. Um, Christians will suffer
and die in tribulation that talks about that in scripture.
Others say it might be spared.
So this says we all go through the great tribulation
and some will die in it.
Okay? Is that true? Or we don't know.
It's also a pro that it's better to prepare for a
post-trip rapture, then a pre-trib rapture.
Because a pre-trib rapture is easy.
It requires nothing of us, we believe.
And then all of a sudden we're just gonna be poof
and we're gone and we're in heaven.
A post-trip, rapture will require everything.
Christians should be prepared to give
of everything for Christ.
There'll be some who fall away, quote unquote Matthew 24,
because they're relying too much on a pre-trib rapture
and too little on Christ himself.
And that's, that's a commendable position.
But it's not an argument in itself
that a post-trip rapture is true.
We, we just don't know.
So we can't definitively say Scripture says
this is how it's going to be.
So that's a lot of the discussion
that comes up when you talk about the end time
schemes, structures.
There's more than that. Those are just kind of the basics.
You could get some more understanding. We got books up here.
You can find stuff online as well.
Alright, so I wanted to leave time
to have some fun conversations about this.
And so I'm gonna invite Steve
and Joe, two of our elders up here to help me with that,
because none of us have all the answers.
And, uh, we'll tell you when we don't know the answer.
But, uh, what we do know is that there's questions.
So you got a mic here and a mic here.
Let's see what happens. And we'll go from there.
Uh, but try to give you as much information
as I could about those things in a basic way.
And then let the Lord just continue
to lead you in those ways.
So what questions do you have? Come up with that or else?
I'm gonna have to come up with questions for these guys.
See what we go from there.
Good evening. I figured there'd be like a line at
the mics already.
Okay. Janie's, yeah.
Some would say that, um,
the prophecies that have already been fulfilled
have been fulfilled literally.
And because of that, and we've talked about, uh,
before at Henderson Hills
about scripture interpreting scripture, uh,
if they've been fulfilled, literally, is it realistic
to think that even though it is apocalyptic literature,
that those events that are detailed in the book
of Revelation will also be literally fulfilled?
Yeah, that's a good question. That's a good question.
I think there's, there's a measure
of the prophecies are not all apocalyptic.
And so some of the prophecies are very literal, very direct.
And so, like to us, a child is born, well, child was born.
So yes, prophecies are fulfilled.
Uh, but that's what I started with earlier about the debates
of how they're fulfilled
and the dual profit, dual fulfillment and things like that.
That they're looking ahead
and seeing things, um, when they were
back then they're looking ahead to future events,
just like we're now looking ahead to future events.
So I think though the fact that some
of those were not apocalyptic prophecies
and were fulfilled literally doesn't necessarily mean
that all of the apocalyptic prophecies that have yet
to come would also have to be fulfilled.
Literally. They might be, they might, but,
but when you read those things, you kind of think, is
that gonna be 10 heads on an eight
beasts and things like that?
Maybe that would be kind of cool to see, I guess.
But, but at the same time, will that happen like that?
So it's a, that's part of the reason the debate happens is
because people would say absolutely, they have
to be literal, all of them,
or there's ways to interpret those things.
When you even look at Ezekiel
and some of the things he was saying
that were then fulfilled later, there's some, I guess,
apocalyptic prophecies he's making that could be considered
fulfilled, not literally as well, even in past tense for us.
Well, I know that a lot of prophecy
teachers will say there is partial fulfillment
in some prophecies.
Uh, there is future fulfillment
and, um, some prophecies are fulfilled
more than once.
Yeah. Which is what you were referring to
I think when you said, you know, some
of those things like AD 70, the temple was destroyed.
Yeah. Um, but was that the tribulation?
Well, probably not, but um,
so, uh, it can be partially fulfilled
or it can be, uh, it could be totally in the future
or it may be fulfilled more than once.
Yeah, the same prophecy. It does, it
Makes, it's the hard part. Hard.
That's the hard, but, yeah. Yeah.
Good question, Jay. Thank you.
Yeah, I, go ahead. I just follow up and agree with that.
Uh, I, I think if we think about the religious experts, uh,
in the second century, uh, BC
looking at the prophecy of Christ, I don't think any
of 'em would've been able
to diagram it out the way it happened.
But from the backside, looking back,
those prophecies make perfect sense.
So I think that's why we have
to hold loosely when somebody says they have the answer.
It doesn't mean we don't study,
but I think we need to hold our conclusions loosely.
But the prophecies do come true.
And I think from the perspective of heaven, we'll say,
oh, that's what it was.
Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah.
John, you can take that off now that we're good. Thank you.
Alright, Jacob.
So I've had a bunch of friends, whether believers
or non-believers when it comes to the questions of
regarding Revelation, one of the biggest ones
that's always stumped me and hard to explain is the 144,000.
Wow. I've always kind of wanted
to have a good explanation on how to go about that.
The 144,000 mm-Hmm. The, yeah. Okay.
You guys experts on that one?
Well, the 144,000, uh, it actually describes
that they come from, uh, particular tribes, uh, of Israel.
So, uh, one would, uh, think that, uh,
that they're Jewish evangelists.
That's, that's the, the mantra
of the pre-trib pre-millennial, uh, perspective.
And I, I sure don't dis I'm not in a position
to disagree with that at all.
Uh, but it, uh, yeah, they're,
Uh, yeah. So
it's Revelation seven, where
12,000 from each Yeah.
Of the 12 tribes.
Yeah. John looks into heaven
and he says, uh, sealed the servants
of our God on their foreheads heard for the number
of the sealed, 144,000 sealed from every tribe with the Sons
of Israel, 12,000 from each of the 12 tribes.
Uh, and that's all it says.
And so then they're sealed is what it says in that.
So the debate commonly people would say that's, yeah,
so the pre-trip Premil perspective would be that that's the
144,000 sealed from the tribulation period
where they were saved from the 12 tribes of Israel,
the ethnic tribes of Israel into
the kingdom of God that way.
Um, others would say those are symbolic numbers,
just like a lot of symbolic numbers in that,
that just illustrates a large number of people
because right after that,
after this, I looked to behold a great multitude no one
could number from every nation,
tribes, peoples, and languages.
So does he distinguish between those two things
that there are specific numbers for people from Israel,
and then are there a great multitude in general?
Yeah, you could make that argument for sure.
Uh, but what we do know is that there will be
believers in Christ come from ethnic Israel at some point.
There already are, have been,
but at some point in the future, more will, whether
that's all of them that's up for debate
or whether that's just those
who would be called like this out of
that to believe in Christ.
Yeah, that could be either way, I think there, yeah.
Yeah. I just want to, my perspective is that
I grew up in, um, in a church in Oklahoma City, um,
the Baptist Temple.
And not long after I was saved in the,
in the early seventies, uh, we began a study on, uh, uh,
the second coming and, uh,
as a youth member of the youth group.
And we used the Hal Lindsey's book,
the Late Great Planet Earth, as something
that we just talked about on and on and on,
and on and on about.
And so, um, so my recollection is
that we were taught, uh,
to readily accept a pre-trib pre-millennial
view at the time.
Uh, and then since that time,
there had been other discussions and other books to read
and things to, uh, to, to talk about.
And recently our community group, we, uh, were using
as kind of a guide for us, a a book entitled 20 Basics.
Every Christian Should Know Why Wayne Gruden
and has a chapter about judgements
and those types of things that has
and presented those views.
So that's another source of things, of information
that you may or may not want to use with
to provide that information.
But, uh, you know, the whole left behind series,
Tim Le Hay books, uh, a lot of things, those types
of things were very popular at the time.
Uh, and so that is a, I remember as a youth, we,
we just spent a lot of time talking about that.
I mean, I'm, and uh, we really did spend a, uh, it had a,
had an effect on me as a sophomore,
junior in high school for sure.
So I think we got You had a question. Yeah.
Yes. Hi. Hey, um,
I'm not sure if this is gonna make sense, but like people
or believers who have already died, are they like in heaven?
Like, do you believe that they're in heaven since
Jesus hasn't come back?
Like, or do you think they're waiting
for like heaven to be good?
Yeah, that, that's a good question.
That's a very common question.
Could you repeat the question?
So it, it's believers who die either already have
or will die before Jesus returns.
Are they in heaven or is there kind of intermediate waiting?
What's that state they would be in for now? Yeah.
You've been in seminary, so
you know the answer to that, right?
So no, great. Um, okay.
So you, you look at, just for example,
you look at Jesus on the cross, two thieves.
They're both gonna die and,
and they're not gonna be resurrected immediately.
That's coming someday. But,
but he looks at the guy who was
just mocking him a second ago,
and this guy still was mocking him,
but this guy looked at him and said, actually, huh,
I believe some something different about you.
Right? What does he say to him?
He says, you'll be with me in paradise today.
So that phrase, along with a few other scriptures, I have
to look 'em up, but is indicating that there is a state
that isn't sleeping.
Soul sleep is one of the comments made that, well,
anybody either believe
or unbeliever die, they go into this sleep state
until Jesus returns to judge separate, send to heaven
and hell, that kind of thing.
We don't believe that because after Roman,
it's Hebrews 9 27, it's destined for man to die once
after that to face the judgment.
Now that teams after that seems to indicate,
could be any time, but the way it's talked about is an
urgent, immediate, you're with God or you're not.
You'll be with me in paradise.
So there's a measure of the way we talk about heaven
may not be helpful because the way the Bible talks about is
new heavens and new earth are coming.
That's the final state, new heavens and new earth right now.
Is it heaven per se? Yeah.
Well, we could say that,
but the way Jesus said is paradise, you'll be
with me in paradise.
So we would say that there is an immediate from death moment
where your soul, absent the body, the body is still buried.
Your soul goes to be with God
or to be in what they call shield
or Hades, uh, not temporary state,
but a, a version of
the end state until Jesus comes back to finalize
that new heavens new earth lake of fire
that we saw in Matthew 25.
So that's the general way we'd understand that.
Yeah. And, and now, uh, I would also say that, uh,
the story of the, uh, rich man
and Lazarus, uh, they say the, uh, Lazarus went to,
uh, the bosom of Abraham.
So we call it the paradise.
Call it, uh, absence of body home with Christ.
Uh, talk about the bosom of Abraham.
So it's a state where apparently your spirit is,
you're connected with uh, Christ,
but your body isn't reunited until the resurrection.
Yeah. So it's not exactly heaven if you think about heaven
as being the, the, uh, recreated heaven, new heavens
and new earth, which is, uh, we believe physical.
Yeah. We would also say
that there's often a comment made about purgatory in
especially Roman Catholic circles.
That's nowhere in the Bible,
because that's where that kind of goes, is
that there's this interim state.
I could maybe work my way out of it
or work my way into like, no, it's fixed.
What did you do with Jesus while you're alive? Yeah.
Your body hasn't been resurrected yet.
You'll be given an eternal body.
Even those who are unbelievers going
to hell forever will be given a resurrected
body that will last forever.
But there's no way to work your way out of one of the other.
Once you're there, it's fixed, it's done.
So, great question though. Yeah. Yeah.
No indulgences, no indulgences, no, none of that.
But Jeff,
So my question, I'm recovering from the left behind series
as a very terrified at an early age.
I don't necessarily hold the same views now,
but my question would be, if we take the rules
of interpreting scripture, you know, it, for instance,
it can't mean for us what it didn't mean for them.
We let scripture interpret scripture.
How can we reconcile that with like,
something like the dispensational view, which is very
prominent, uh, especially in a lot of our churches, uh,
Baptist churches, and here in Oklahoma.
How can we reconcile that when so much
of the dispensational views seems to be focused on, uh,
how would you put it just like focused on us, you know?
Yeah. China or Russia is, you know,
Putin is the antichrist and then,
or Ronald Reagan used to be the antichrist,
and then now, you know, it seems to change so much.
How can we reconcile with that?
Uh, or should we just say that's probably not true,
you know, is it healthy to have that?
Or is it, I don't know. That's
A good question. Yeah.
Yeah.
That, that, that's where we can get serious.
Got thoughts. Go ahead and repeat, repeat the question.
So again, I I catch most of it.
Yeah. So we've got this, um, he's, he's recovering left
behind this guy, you know, so, um, this idea that
was so prevalent and prominent in our day is this
dispensational idea, pre-millennial idea,
yet it doesn't seem to square with scripture.
So how do we reconcile that?
If we, do we just let it kind of sit,
or do we press into it a little bit more?
Yeah. I guess what I would say my preference,
if you wanna call it that, is the pre-millennial, uh,
pre tribulational, uh, perspective as taught in more
or less in the Hal Lindsay series.
Uh, and,
and there are, uh, reasons to say, well, does
that exactly fit, does
that exactly flow the way revelation flows?
'cause there are things that show up sort of outta sequence
that, uh, you might say, well,
you know, there's a lot of things going on
and you kind of have to patch it together to make the,
the dispensational plan sort of work out.
Um, but, uh, I think the, the key is, and,
and the thing that concerns me about that is
that people are majoring on prophecy
and trying
to become Bible experts on prophecy at the expense of, uh,
bringing people to Christ, uh, growing them in Christ,
and, uh, reaching others for Christ.
'cause that, that's the instruction that was left with us.
So it's, I'm not so concerned with the,
not so concerned with, uh, the conclusions
because you get into the other issue of, okay, is it, uh,
is the church or place Israel?
Is it Israel that comes back, uh, a lot of scriptures
that can be looked at different ways.
And again, you know, is the next thing
that happens is Christ come, or for us.
Uh, and and what I can tell you is, is where I've landed is
and believe is that the, uh, coming of Christ is imminent.
And it'll either be in, in my perspective,
it'll be pre-trib,
because I think we're gonna recognize those things when they
happen that happen in the tribulation, or it'll be il
but the thing is that Christ is coming.
That's the, that's the next thing that's gonna happen.
It's imminent. It can happen at any time.
It could also have happened at any time
when the New Testament was being written 2000 years ago,
and it could be 2000 years from now.
And so to, to get off track
and say, uh, we're gonna camp out on the hill
'cause we, we know what, what day it's gonna be.
Scripture clearly tells us to be ready.
And Jesus said he didn't, father hadn't even told him,
uh, when he's coming back.
But I think that sort of the lesson for us, uh, is that, uh,
here at Henderson Hills, we wanna have a big tent
with respect to last things.
There are things
that have to be true to be biblical,
and we don't need to divide over
which camp we get into.
Yeah. Yeah. And I would just in light
of your question about kinda where, what do we do with it?
Um, the true dispensational,
pre-trib premil thought process didn't really show up
until the late 18 hundreds.
Doesn't make us wrong. Right?
I mean, church was wrong in some
ways for a really long time.
So it doesn't make it wrong that it's new, uh,
but it does cause us to think, alright, let's,
let's make sure we're not just considering this from a
Western American perspective
that just makes it about me all the time.
That I want comfort and no suffering, uh,
because the Bible's full of it
and just says, this is, you're gonna go
through really hard times, it's gonna get worse.
Things like that. So I think that's where, like Joe said,
just handle it carefully.
Big tent. Um, this should be a sand issue
that we can sit in the same room,
same conversation about this
and say, yeah, I'm historic prem mill, right?
I, I believe we're gonna go through tribulation
and here's what this is, and I'm gonna over here.
I'm, I'm all mill. You know, I think we're in the middle
of it right now and it's fine.
And okay, praise God, Jesus coming back. Yep.
Alright, let's go. So that's what we can get to, I think.
But, but it does make sense for us to really stop
and analyze everything.
Like, like Steve said, everything
that we've grown up hearing
doesn't mean we question everything.
It just means we say, maybe that's not as
straight line biblical as I thought it was.
Maybe I need to really just do my
own research and think through.
And so that's part of showing those five different options.
Maybe you've never seen some of those before.
You're like, oh, that makes a little sense too.
Oh, they, yeah. 'cause they all kind of do
and there's enough scriptures to back all of them up.
We need to be careful with them. Yeah.
Have nothing against Kirk. Cameron.
Kirk Cameron's a great guy. We love Kirk. Yes.
Uh, that's awesome. Yeah.
Okay. So, uh, there are those who say that, uh,
prophecy in the Bible makes up anywhere from 25
to 33% of the scriptures in the Bible.
So what,
what do we think, uh, the point?
Why did God put those prophecies in there?
That's one thing,
and my personal opinion is that, uh, prophecy,
uh, makes the Bible the most unusual book,
particularly when we look at the ones
that have been fulfilled.
Yeah. You talked about, uh,
focusing so much on prophecy
that we essentially forget the gospel.
But to me, as I, as I have read
through the scriptures many times,
there are things happening today that, um,
look like they could be setting up
for the final fulfillment that are left,
that remain to be fulfilled.
So the point being, our time
may be short, it could be 200 years away, two or whatever.
But the honest truth is not a single one
of us know the number of our days.
So that makes it imperative to,
we can talk about prophecy,
but we have to get to the message of the gospel,
which is there is not a single
innocent human being on the face of the earth.
We're all sinners. A judgment is coming. Yeah.
Are you prepared for it? That's right.
That's Right. But back to the initial question,
why was prophecy put in the word?
Yeah, that, that's a good question.
I think there's, there's a lot of, um,
warnings that come with it.
When you think about even Paul in, in his letters would,
would warn Christians not to fall away.
Mm-Hmm. And, and so in the same, in the same letter,
he says, thank you for your faithfulness.
I'm so proud of you for staying steadfast. Don't fall away.
That doesn't how, wait, how did you get there, Paul?
Like, they aren't falling away,
but I think he's saying to them, stay alert,
which would be part of what the prophetic language
about judgment and all that it, it is coming
how we, we could debate.
But, but I think that's enough of the warning there to say
to unbelievers even
and to us, don't fall away.
Don't stay steadfast and to an unbeliever.
This is coming and it's going
to be worse than you can ever imagine.
So see the opportunity of, like you said,
tying the gospel with it to say,
and part of the prophecy is that he predicted.
So you're reading Daniel and Ezekiel,
and there's this lament and woe is us and judgment's coming,
but he also looked forward to a savior.
Yeah. And that prophecy was fulfilled.
There is, there is hope. 300 plus times different
things were fulfilled in that baby coming.
So don't you think you can trust
that there is a judgment coming too?
Maybe you need to consider this savior
who spares you from judgment by taking it on himself.
That's the where you get the gospel with that. Yeah. Yeah.
So some warning to us, uh,
because we can tend to get comfortable, we can really,
as believers we can, walking away, that just gets lazy.
And so the warnings of prophecy
and even the letters,
Hebrews talks a lot about warning believers.
Like we need to be careful and alert.
I have a niece who, uh, is not a believer,
and I asked her if she would share with me
why she no longer believed.
And I am in the process of preparing a response.
She, I had asked her several weeks ago,
she finally responded today.
And I think prophecy fulfilled certainly helps
validate the truth that's contained in God's word.
Um, and it make,
it does make it different from any other book
because many of these prophecies were for foretold hundreds
of years, if not thousands
before they eventually were fulfilled.
That makes it a very unique book
and provides validity for it. Yeah.
Yeah. The, uh, just real quick, one
of the resources we had, it says the second coming
of Christ is mentioned 1,845 times in the Bible,
1,527 in the Old Testament, 318 in the New Testament.
And people are exhorted over 50 times
to be ready for his return.
So just by counting Yeah. That, that's a
Lot. That's a lot. Yeah.
So it is absolutely important.
We gotta, we gotta be done. But it is absolutely important.
Don't let it consume us by focusing so
and exclusively on it that we lose the bigger picture
that Christ is, the victor already has one will win.
We stand in victory, in triumph in him
and stay steadfast.
Yeah. Just, just till that thought.
Yeah. Uh, we are entering the end times.
We entered the end times when Christ arose
2000 years ago, uh, 2000 years ago.
So we've been in the end times,
and it could very well be that those signs
that are happening now are the signs of, of the coming, uh,
tribulation and things are setting up.
But let's don't forget that, uh,
in the year 99, 99, I'll tell you,
there was a pretty big bunch of folks who
Were waiting for the millennium to start the year 1000.
Right. And, uh, they were way disappointed.
They weren't taking care of business
and living their lives for Christ and reaching people.
Uh, and if I have a concern about the, uh,
dispensational, if you call it, I call it the pre-trib,
pre-millennial perspective, is that we have people who are
so convinced that this is it,
that they're patting themselves on the back,
that they're good, we're good.
Uh, aren't we smart? That we know so much about it.
And we can talk about, you know, whether Gog and Mago
or China
or the armies from the East 200 million
man army from the East is China.
You know, now they've got that many people in
their military.
So you get so wrapped up in it that, uh,
it takes your eye off the ball of what we're to be about
and living the Christian life, maturing in Christ,
helping others ma mature in Christ and loving them.
Yeah. So that's, that's the only caution I have. And it's
Good's. Good. Thank
you for that. Steve. You got one more thing?
And then pray for us if you would please.
A final word is that it just, the song, the King is Coming
by Bill and Gloria Gaither just keeps ringing in my mind.
'cause I was sitting at the Baptist Temple Church.
We'd just sing. The King is Coming and we had the big Tempe,
and we'd play that Tempe and there would be tears
and there'd be excitement.
And so I'll just say, uh, the king is coming. Let's pray.
You gonna sing it for us first?
No. Well, no, I won't. Oh man.
They'll not let me in the quiet
Open. That was coming.
Oh,
Heavenly Father, thank you for tonight.
And just thank you for the opportunity to be together.
Uh, I appreciate each person here tonight,
and I thank you for, for John
as he led us through these questions.
And as he, uh, continues to teach us, Lord,
uh, the king is coming.
And, uh, let us be prepared.
Let us, uh, let us continue to share the gospel.
Every opportunity that we have, let us love one another.
Let's make disciples of, of people
that we have the opportunity to come into contact with.
Thank you for the blessed hope.
Thank you for everything you do for us.
Go, go with us tonight and keep us safe.
Your name I pray. Amen.
Amen. Amen. Good, good, good.